President Trump says the world needs to
confront North Korea over its nuclear
threat in Poland this morning the
president condemned the North very
dangerous behavior but he also said he
will not draw any red lines as far as
North Korea is concerned I don't know
we'll see what happens I don't like to
talk about what I have planned but I
have some pretty severe things that
we're thinking about that doesn't mean
we're going to do them
the president spoke one day after his UN
Ambassador raised a prospect of military
action against North Korea he also
touched on other issues including Russia
major Garrett is traveling with the
president he is near Krasinski Square in
Warsaw where the president is about to
make a speech major good morning good
morning president Trump addressed by far
the biggest issue here say the United
States remains committed to deterring
any type of military conflict in Europe
the president also criticized what he
called Russia's destabilizing behavior
but once again refused to blame Moscow
solely for election meddling in 2016 as
for North Korea there was ominous
rhetoric but no timetable or roadmap for
next steps what happens over the coming
weeks and months with respect to North
Korea it's a shame that they're behaving
this way but they are behaving in a very
very dangerous manner and something will
have to be done about it president
Trump's vague response left uncertain
how to deter North Korea's pursuit of
ballistic missile technology needed for
a nuclear strike against the US current
administration options include
pressuring China and other nations to
limit north korea's access to capital
and labor before leaving for Europe mr.
Trump asked the Pentagon for fresh
military options in North Korea I think
it was Russia and I think it could have
been other people in other countries in
advance of his first face-to-face
meeting with Russian President Vladimir
Putin mr. Trump injected doubt into US
intelligence assessments that Putin
directed Russia's unprecedented cyber
meddling in the 2016 election I think it
was Russia but I think it was probably
other people and/or countries
I see nothing wrong with that statement
nobody really knows what issue the US
will raise with Russia next steps in
Syria Secretary of State Rex Tillerson
echoing Obama administration policy said
the US goal is to cooperate with Russia
on Syria's political future after Isis
is defeated now this is where we've
begun an effort to begin to rebuild
confidence between ourselves and Russia
at the military-to-military level but
also the diplomatic level but we're at
the very beginning and I would say at
this point it's difficult to say exactly
what the Russia's Russia's intentions
are in this relationship in a speech to
the Polish people momentarily President
Trump will cite Poland as an example of
a nation showing the world how best to
defend Western civilization Jeff the
Polish government's recent crackdown on
press freedoms and the courts and its
hardline stance on immigration have left
it out of step with many of the European
leaders president Trump will soon meet
with at the g20 summit in Hamburg
Germany major Garrett thank you very
much